our series changing the game highlights
extraordinary women who are making a
difference now and for future
Generations so for Black History Month
we're focusing on black entrepreneurs
and creators this morning we want to
introduce you to Sophia Danner okota she
created the fashion brand basita back in
2015 when she couldn't find fashion in
America that represented her African
Roots she said I'm gonna do something
about that the sustainable clothing line
features African prints and Designs
handmade in Nigeria by local tailors
Sophia Danner okay as you see sitting
here who are you wearing today I am
wearing
she was featured in Forbes 30 under 30
list in 2021 we welcome you we're so
glad you walked in the room we went oh
we like that yeah so thank you so your
background is not in fashion designing
you started this you had no formal
training absolutely not what were you in
10 tending to do what was your job I
wanted to sit right there where you are
getting in this chair
right between them I actually have a
news background I worked for the CBS
affiliate in Macon Georgia 13 WMAZ and I
had dreams and aspirations to become a
national journalist I was I loved it I
loved investigative news I really
thought it was my calling yeah and then
what happened and then this happened I
felt deep down as far as bessita I felt
deep down that I needed to create
something that I was really really
passionate about something that
connected women to Africa and all at the
same time connecting Africa to the rest
of the world so I think of besida as
Africa giving to us and us giving to
Africa does basita mean something is
that yes yes it's very special to me it
means Destiny determines all oh wow it's
part of the ishakiri language in Nigeria
which is the tribe that I'm from was
there a First garment or print that Drew
you to design well that's the thing is
when you enter the markets in Nigeria
there are lots of prints lots of options
so it was very hard for me to choose but
a particular design that I think we
started creating which is a little later
on was our formida it was a piece that
you could wear as three blouses and a
skirt and that's when I really felt like
we were on to something because we
weren't just going to give a consumer a
piece of cloth that you can wear we're
going to give you multiple styling
options three blouses and a skirt in one
outfit in one outfit whenever people say
this I take it home and I go how the
hell does this work because it says yeah
you got to have a vision well do you oh
you just have to be time I could never
wrap it the right way tie it the same
way even though there's even though I've
seen people you can make a skirt you can
make a dress you can make it I can never
understand how to do that and you say
what to that I say we've got enough
tutorials for you to learn there's a few
options
yeah so that's the for me Dom so she's
wearing it as a tube top and also as a
skirt and it was only supposed to be a
tube top you know I was wearing it one
day instead of pulling it from the top
was pulling it from the bottom he said
hold up wait a minute and my manager
said wait I thought this was a Top This
is actually a skirt and I said well then
I could do you either put it on the
waist you just put it above it on top or
just show your hand through and make it
a one shoulder now you keep mentioning
um being connected to your roots and how
designing these garments gives you that
feeling oftentimes feel like
African-Americans here in the states we
yearn for that but don't necessarily
know how to create that bridge why do
you believe clothing is a great bridge
for black folks in America to connect to
their Roots I think clothing is an easy
way to do it just because everyone loves
to feel good and I say there's power in
Prince as well when you have these
garments on it's not just I have on a
beautiful garment it's an expression of
culture yeah it's an expression of
Heritage and what we've noticed is we've
inspired people to also go back home and
what we've started doing is really
taking a step forward with our mission
and given away trips to Africa so our
first winner is going to be going to
Ghana in April wow hearing about Ghana I
want to go I'm looking at your dress is
that reversible yes this skirt
absolutely is so you can wear it both as
a print and also on the other side you
can wear it as a solid color because
some people are print shy so okay so
talk about print shy because I think
that's really interesting how do you
know a print is working and what do you
say to the prince shy to give it a try
because everyone wearing prints in here
right now looks great yeah colleague
over there we got the wall yeah I love
Prince yeah yeah so I I think I have I'm
the sauce okay I've got the I've got the
secret I know how to look at a print and
say that's gonna work yeah um if I'm
kind of questioning my thoughts I'll
present it to one of my friends and and
say what do you think about this and
they'll give me
um they'll give me better ideas of
course but so did you just I know did
you just go to Nigeria and you started
looking at all these different prints
and then you started designing so
started drawing so literally that's what
I did so when I went back home on a trip
I went to the markets and the markets
are such inspiration they're so they're
buzzing with so much culture so much so
many colors and I picked out a few
prints I had a few designs in my mind
very simple cuts and my tailors brought
it to life I just had a team of maybe
two tailors at the time and we just made
a size like small medium large extra
large that's all and we brought it to
America started selling it out of my
trunk where can people get get you now
where can they get you shop basita.com
s-h-o-p-b-e-s-i-d-a.com so do you regret
not sitting here in this chair between
Nate and Tony are you happier doing what
you're doing you know I always say this
that our idea of what's great is nothing
compared to God's best for us and I am
living in God's dream for my life so I
do not regret it but but guess what I'm
hearing right
thank you we'll be right back good job
Sophia well